are you doing today sir
doing great rhenium I'm serious right by
the way what this this has to be I mean
it's a lot of people wait their whole
career to have reviews and a film that
strikes people so strongly right you
know it's a it's it's great when for you
when did you realize was it onset that
you realized that we're making something
special or is it almost like you need to
see the finished film to know sort of
how it's gonna come together I think
it's every it's all the above I think I
was just saying in another interview
that we finished the day we finished day
one and we shot pretty much sequentially
so we've finished that seemed Marcia in
the bedroom the open to the film and a
number of other scenes on the first day
and I thought to myself huh he's not
directing me to be demonstrative this is
good it's like here you know this we're
all on the same page here and then I
think there was a feeling when we
finished that we had made something
special and certainly I remember coming
back to New York and me agents looking
at some other projects and remember even
having a feeling then and saying you
know you guys I think I think I can take
a little bit of a pause I feel really
good about what we did in Italy and then
I was just seeing at Sundance the first
time and and having an authentic
experience as a viewer that I'm sure not
everybody's gonna have I'm watching it
because to think that would be to be
naive but certainly it's been very
gratifying to seeing the work people
have a positive reaction to it and
particularly Michael Stuhlbarg smiling
at me in the film and to hear people say
that they had either had a parent like
that or had a deep desire to have a
parent like that it's very moving to be
a part of anything to be an
infinitesimally involved with something
like that completely I've seen a lot of
actors that talk about how when there's
no ever performance that when they go
home at night they almost have to not
method like Daniel day-lewis but like
they stay in character a little bit
because it helps them with their
performance and some people lifes won't
be new it's like a light switch and then
get off set it flip the switch they're
done until they come back the next day
for you in a role like this
how much are you staying in maybe the
mindset
when you go home and how much is it for
you you're able to just you know it's a
light switch I think it depends on the
day really and and you kind of you you
kind of self-diagnose almost like a golf
caddy or something with a golfer and to
figure out maybe you do need a little
bit more character research that night
or maybe you go back to the source
material or maybe you work on the
dialect or what have you or often the
prescription can be okay totally forget
it put on Family Guy or Netflix whatever
it is sure you know because it's tough
to watch movies when you're shooting
something it can be intimidating so I
watched a lot of documentaries or
cartoons or what have you I will say
like I know a big thing a big part of my
experience of call me by name but also
in on the projects like beautiful boy
I've worked on since that are based on
source material is that and the
pre-production process
you almost militantly become the
character and forget any and all actor
or storytelling instincts towards not
being boring and just almost rigidly
focus on what that person's experience
would be like and for calling of our
name was listening to the kinds of music
kind of that kind of music from the 80s
or listening to a lot of Bach or Ravel
or busoni or at least or to have you but
then I find once I start a project then
it's very much you bring up the portable
speaker and listen to contemporaneous
music order because you've done the
research then drank and you have it in
you and then it's no longer about you
know acting and from the mirror acting
for yourself for creating this character
within your within your head space but
rather being a good ensemble member
being a good storyteller and
communicating the story of the audience
in a way that's makes sense with what
this source material was when Andre
Houseman wrote and then just hoping for
the best and and and then beyond any
sort of character traits or little
mannerisms that you think out for
yourself like I said you you become an
ensemble man where you become one with
the relationship in the story where it's
less about what you're doing and more
that this love story between the boys
comes across sure a lot of the actors I
speak to they talk about they like some
people love the Clint Eastwood method of
shooting the rehearsal doing to take or
to and trying to move on and others love
the Fincher method what 4050 takes what
do you typically like to do and how does
Luca like to do it and maybe how does
that
you know man these are such great
questions I'm shocked anybody would even
pay half a thought to what I have to say
it about this but uh I think again it
just depends on what the project is for
me for something like this it's very
much I'd like to leave it to the moment
like we would rehearse but god forbid
you get it right and rehearsal then with
something as intimate and and so in the
moment are you going full force in the
rehearsal or you know no yeah no in fact
no you you I find I like especially in
film certainly this is not the
experience on stage on stage you're
trying to give it time to try to figure
it out and the place I've done that's
the approach I have but in film you you
almost want to give a rehearsal with the
director whether you know you feel like
the directors like home and you know why
is he doing it my fed or whatever so on
the day you can bring it and kind of you
don't want to set yourself up for
failure by doing it really great in a
rehearsal or not in an audition and then
not being able to bring it on the day
that was another amazing thing about not
having to read this in advance I had the
belief and the knowledge that Luca
desired me as an actor which is rare as
a young actor because people really
don't know I don't have a lot of work
behind me so and so rightfully there's a
a not sufficient but a trepidation
towards it so in a project like this
especially because we're shooting on
film you know two three takes and you
save whatever behaviorally will play out
what the truth of that is physically and
specifically to this film with such a
push and pull dial a wrestling match of
sorts between these two characters you
know you kind of save it for the moment
save for the very you know intimate or
more sexually out-there stuff that you
wanting block out a little bit more
carefully not a project like beautiful
boy which is a film I did this past
spring with Steve Carell we're very
familiar I'm looking forward to a night
yeah I can't wait to see it see it
either and that's also have Felix fine
going again the director that projects
we get broken circle break down a number
of other excellent films likes to work I
used to do like 14 to 16 takes and and
then that it is it doesn't it doesn't
give you room at the top of the number
of takes you do in fact I'm sure a lot
of the takes and then that we're using
that film or things that are at the top
and yet it gives you room to keep
playing and keep finding to keep going
to keep going and it was crucial to the
nature of that project because
many scenes as it's only truthful the
circumstance of being in rehab at a
young age or dealing with addiction at a
young age and you know these were
emotional climaxes that as an actor it
would almost be unhealthy to be able to
bring it out of yourself like that on
cue so there were some times was the
requisite of doing eight or nine or ten
or eleven takes and something happens on
the twelfth one or whatever and then yet
I can think of a scene we did outside in
San Francisco at 3:00 a.m. that's pretty
much one of these emotional climaxes and
was freezing and I was in a t-shirt and
there was one of those ones we got
almost right away so it depends on a
day-to it's how you wake up you know I
spoke to Fincher and he told me that
sometimes the whole craft of wasn't
obviously the way he crafts performances
are unbelievable uneatable he said to me
that like sometimes I'll use part of
take three take 17 and take 40 to craft
the performance and I'm like that's been
crazy yeah never was crazy and it
reminds me of a Dustin Hoffman story
that I heard in a podcast once he ran in
here in an interviewer he's doing a film
with Robert DeNiro that De Niro was
directing I should really know the title
but then he said you know the Dustin
Hoffman's didn't get any like playing
that his entire arc he knew exactly what
he wanted to do with it at a very
specific idea for the scene and that
when DeNiro directed himself in the
scene he would just do like he would do
it a line at the top a line at a time
and do it like five or six different
ways and then so you go in the editing
room and just cut it in dirt Lee's so
you know being a theater guy and going
to perform an arts high school I'm very
much more of the mentality that not to a
specific physical ization because also
as an actor I really just do you like to
physicalize stuff yeah well I don't try
to plot it out to that degree but I want
to have an idea of where it's going
particularly when you're not dealing
with lead roles even supporting roles
like an Lady Bird or what I did in
hostiles or an interstellar then it's
like very important to know okay this is
how this is how I would like to do and
obviously on the day you're gonna be
ready for the director to say that you
have an accent or something completely
when you you're getting obviously this
is a this is a challenging bit of
material and you know really it requires
everyone to really go for it and go say
you're reading the script you're getting
ready to film the whole movie was what
was the thing that maybe you were most
nervous about filming that ended up
being like super easy and maybe
something you thought would be easy
ended up being a little bit more
challenging did that ever happen yeah
okay okay um I think and the thing we
talked about laughs at the most but that
there's there's a there's the peach
scene so that just like circumstantially
from what's required from that scene I
just had a doubt whether anybody could
do that believably if it worked better
as a literary metaphor than it ever
could visually and then I was I think
both Luke and I were surprised on the
day that oh okay maybe this can play out
believably also the piano sequences were
and so the point being that when we did
it I was that was one of those scenes
for coming up our name I thought we
would do eight or nine takes but we did
too and it felt like okay we had it and
so it was awesome the piano sequence was
anxious in the sense that I was out
there a month and a half to learn the
piano so when it came time to do it I
thought okay here we go you know put
your money where your mouth is
and show me you can do it and then
conversely it's the last scene we shot
in the movie and it's towards the end
it's a final kiss where it kind of goes
out of focus and it's right after I've
thrown up in the fountain we kind of
walk over and the Wade screwed it was
scripted like the most passionate
because through something like that it
was something really special it was
there was a signifying script that I was
in that case was supposed to be special
and I think the actor instinct kind of
takes over that special is their movie
physicalize would be something big to it
and I think not so much army but I think
I remember struggling with that scene
that and I'd taken Luke and encouraging
me to this is about this is about the
emotion and what sentiments being
communicated here not behaviorally how
you were doing it I think it when taken
particularly we were kissing and then
army kind of moved his head back to take
a pause from the kissing and I think I
like punch the wall Mike soon or
something out of frustration Luke he
said cut cut you know like that doesn't
make any sense here you know and and
you're trying to tell me that Luke
erected this in the way to and I'm
joking no no yeah yeah by the I of
course by the way uh so and there are a
number of examples of that where I felt
free physically and free to be
spontaneous because if it make any sense
as many things I did that make sense
there's not a movie so completely I know
wouldn't be the approach to every kind
of role and certainly I felt like and I
still feel like a prescription to just
to just be in so many scenes in this
movie is something that'll be
hard-pressed to find again it's
something like beautiful boy were on
secondary Steve Quarles characters and
it was much more not choice oriented but
I I know I'm a little more restrained
we've talked about the fact that Luca
his first cut was like three hours 40
minutes is a number of deleted scenes
is there a scene or two that you were a
little sad to see go um it was like a
birthday party I don't know if that is
if I just misheard that um
there you know
weirdly there's there's a scene with
Michael Stuhlbarg and America's our
plays my mother where our mean our
having that conversation outside towards
the end of the film spoiler alert
where we're discussing you know that was
time we lost and that we didn't
consummate our love quicker and what a
shame that was and they there's a cut
work Michael and army and over the Mike
with a Michael and a half the subplot no
read about Michael and Amira in bed
listening to the conversation the
conversation kind of bleeds through the
window and then Michael and Amir are
kind of turned on by him and look at and
it didn't make age of the film and
besides but that would be what would
have been fascinating what a
circumstantial prescription of that
scene well his lost as the production
design that bedroom was awesome and I
think would have been the closest
glimpse into what Suspiria is gonna look
like in the fall it was how there
how many had a province bedroom like
that's interesting I listen man I gotta
go or you have to go I'm gonna say
seriously congratulations thank you
movie